JEROMY CARRIERE: Welcome.
Before I get started, I want
to kind of do a quick question.
Developers?
OK.
Sort of management types?
Which I can say
without any slight,
since I am such a thing.
Oh, good.
OK.
Anybody I didn't get
with those two categories
that's willing to admit it?
No.
OK.
Fair enough.
So, as Tom said,
I'm Jeromy Carriere.
I'm an engineering director
here at Google in New York.
I'm responsible for all of
Google's monitoring, logging,
alerting, sort of
operational systems,
both facing Google's
internal users
and facing our cloud customers.
So if you've seen
Google Cloud Monitoring,
that's my team's project.
I was told to offer a little
bit of human interest,
so my human interest is my
daughter's joining us today.
She brought me to a One
Direction concert last night,
so this is payback.
Yeah.
She's going to have
to stay all day.
So, does anybody-- I was
going through these slides.
I'm thinking, like,
does anybody really
need to be sold on
why cloud is a thing?
Does anybody need to be sold
on why cloud is a thing?
Does anybody not believe it?
OK.
Good.
Anyway.
I'm forced to go
through the slides.
CEOs.
We've talked to lots of CEOs.
They see technology change
as driving their business.
That's likely been
truth for all time.
But right now, the
key thing that's
driving businesses
globally is the cloud.
Again, I probably don't
need to sell you too much.
There are a few key elements
to that, things that are really
pushing cloud as a thing today.
Mobile, obviously,
is a huge one, right?
People are using their own
devices in the workplace.
Common pattern, 53%,
I think, is the number
of people bringing
their own mobile devices
into the workplace.
Any time.
We need to be able to access
data wherever you are,
whenever.
Any time of day.
From anywhere in the world.
We need people.
We need collaboration.
That's a huge driver today.
The key thing that I like to
focus on is this idea of speed.
Right?
So I'm sort of subscribed
to the philosophy
that velocity is paramount.
Everything else you can fix
if you can deliver quickly.
So spending time,
as most enterprises
do-- 67% of
engineering effort goes
into maintaining
existing systems-- that
just saps velocity.
So how do we fix that?
What is it that we
can do about it?
And that's where we
come-- ah, sorry.
One more motivational slide.
Mobile.
People don't really
even appreciate
that cloud services are
part of their daily lives.
Whether it's iCloud or pick
your favorite start up.
It's likely running on
our cloud or on AWS.
Not a surprise.
So it's in everybody's
lives all the time.
A vast majority of
the workload that's
running on Google's
Cloud Platform today
is actually being driven
by mobile applications.
IT trends are the sort of
fundamental building blocks
that are pushing
this momentum today.
So the first is
affordable capacity.
Today-- this is a stat I
didn't even actually know
until I read these
slides-- $600 can buy
enough storage for
the world's music.
That's pretty neat.
$500-$600.
On demand.
You can get compute
capacity when you need it,
with basically no ramp, right?
There's no time.
You don't have to
wait to get capacity.
As a startup, as
any enterprise, you
can get going with zero
capital expenditure.
You can rent your
way to massive scale.
And then, finally,
global networks
in their current state--
Google having one of the best--
is we can deliver information,
anywhere in the world,
to any device,
extremely quickly.
So these are the trends that
are pushing all this together.
In case that you're not
sold, I found this also
very compelling.
In 1957, the average age of
a company joining the S&P 500
was 75 years.
In 2013, it was 10 years.
So if you don't believe that
the enterprise is changing,
I think this should
be compelling.
Google.
Everyone knows Google's
mission statement.
We're forced to memorize it.
Tattoo it.
Organize the world's information
and make it universally
accessible and useful.
Of course, this
started with Search.
Google Search was
Sergey and Larry
in their, whatever,
dorm at Stanford.
That was where Google began.
And that required a
lot of infrastructure.
Over the years
since Google began,
there has been an enormous
amount of infrastructure built,
rebuilt, rebuilt again, globally
to deliver on that mission
statement.
That means that we are running
some of the largest distributed
systems in the
world, with extremely
stringent requirements
in terms of latency,
in terms of reliability.
Doing this required solving
a lot of problems, right?
How do you actually not
just store multiple copies
of the web, which is one thing--
you can put it on a hard drive
and stick in the
closet, right?--
but making it accessible
globally with low latency.
Making it queryable
in rich ways.
Applying the Knowledge
Graph to overlay
the raw index of the web.
And then expanding
that, of course,
into the rest of our
product portfolio.
That's required us to solve some
really interesting problems.
And just to look at
one-- networking.
So Google has a
fantastic global network
in terms of reliability,
in terms of latency,
in terms of raw throughput,
spanning the globe.
To get there,
Google actually had
to reinvent the way
telecom was done.
For the most part, we actually
have our own dedicated fiber
spanning the globe.
That's kind of one aspect of
the sort of physical plant
side of things.
But there's a lot of
software here, right?
Google engineers are
exceptionally smart.
Some examples are shown here.
And these are the
ones that we've
talked about most publicly.
And you see, as you
go to the right,
you're moving toward more public
offerings like Compute Engine.
But back in 2002, the
problem was, how do you
store multiple copies of the
web and make them accessible?
So the Google File System.
Then, how do you actually
process that much data?
That's MapReduce.
And then how do
you actually make
it queryable in
an online fashion?
Building a storage
system is one thing,
but then actually making it
queryable for online access
is another thing.
That's Bigtable.
But how do you
make it expressive?
How do you actually
allow users that
want to ask questions
of that data--
how do we make them productive?
Well, that's Dremel, or
otherwise known externally
as BigQuery.
And then another
interesting point
here is that Colossus is the
replacement for Google File
System.
So even in this one
slide, there are already
cycles of wax and wane
of a given technology.
So as we learned about
GFS, it taught us
what we needed to do
in the next generation.
That's Colossus.
And then you see
Spanner, which is
a strongly consistent global
database-- which sort of flies
in the face of much of the
accumulated wisdom of software
engineering these
days, which counsels
us to relax
consistency constraints
and favor availability
over consistency.
And that's the Bigtable model.
But as we observed how
Googlers build applications,
we discovered that
actually finding a way
to build a global,
consistent database
makes many problems
easier to solve.
And that's embodied in Spanner.
And then, finally,
taking everything
we've learned about building
global compute infrastructures,
global physical
compute clusters,
has led us to Compute Engine,
Google Compute Engine.
So that's all well
and good, right?
That's fun for us.
But what does it mean to you?
Well, the good news is that
the Google Cloud Platform,
the compute engine I mentioned
in the previous slide,
is one example.
It's actually built on
the same infrastructure
that powers Google itself.
So underneath, as I
said, BigQuery is Dremel.
Underneath another-- just quick
example-- underneath Google
Cloud Storage is a product
that we use internally
called Blobstore.
And I can sort of repeat this
pattern over and over again.
So the portfolio.
The products that we offer
as part of the Google Cloud
Platform.
Loosely, in three large buckets.
Compute, that's
hosting applications.
App Engine and
Compute Engine, which
we'll get into in a second.
And you'll hear more, of
course, throughout the rest
of the afternoon on
these things in depth.
The storage products.
Cloud Storage, Cloud
SQL, Cloud Datastore.
So Datastore, with an
affinity to App Engine.
Cloud SQL, hosted SQL offering.
Cloud Storage, the Blobstore
I mentioned a second ago.
And then high-level
application services.
Cloud Endpoints.
This is the facility we
have for allowing you
developers to build APIs
hosted by App Engine.
And BigQuery, again, is our
SQL-like large data query
capability.
Sort of a columnar-inspired
query system.
So that's the quickest possible
pass through the platform.
Just to reflect on how Google
Cloud Platform is evolving.
So I've only been
at Google 18 months.
So 18 months ago, coming into
Google, Cloud, in all honesty,
seemed like a bit
of a novelty to me.
It didn't seem like it was
really core to our business.
That, I can swear, has changed.
We have as an organization, as
an engineering organization,
as a business, have applied
an enormous amount of energy
to the cloud platform.
And you can see that reflected
in just this small slice
of the products that
we've delivered just
in the last year.
Since last August.
Everything from
Encryption at Rest,
which seems like kind
of a table-stakes thing,
all the way through stuff
that we were talking about.
Tom mentioned before Containers,
Google Cloud Monitoring, which
I'll talk about, I
think, on the next slide.
And all through this, there's
been a consistent theme
of reducing prices to better
reflect the costs that we
actually incur at Google, which
I'll get into in a second.
So developers are
moving to Cloud,
because it's always
going to be lower cost.
We can always, as a
company like Google,
run it more inexpensively
than you, an enterprise, can.
And that sounds like
it's easy to say.
But it's actually true.
The economics are fundamentally
different for an organization
like Google.
And I'll come back
to that in a second.
Then there's a question of
flexibility and adaptability.
We are striving to build
a cloud platform that
eliminates lock-in.
Now, there's only so
far you can go, right?
If you believe me,
and I said everything
you build a Google
platform is 100% portable,
you'd be right in
questioning that.
But we are striving to not
just adhere to standards,
but drive standards
to make that true.
And then finally, we want
to allow you, the developer,
to focus on customers.
Energy you spend constructing,
managing, monitoring,
and maintaining
infrastructure is
time you're not
spending building value
to your business.
Something that your
customers are going to love.
And we want to obviate that.
Cloud economics.
So-- this is the point I made
a second ago-- even if you were
sort of thinking
cloud-wise, and you're
building a private cloud, unless
you had an extremely diverse
workload, if you're a
very large enterprise,
you can imagine how you
could drive that curve down
towards the public cloud curve.
But we, as a cloud provider,
have the opportunity
to optimize in terms
of economies of scale.
We have the opportunity to hire
in a way that is really just
not possible unless you're
running a cloud platform.
And we have an opportunity
to multiplex workloads.
And this is a really
interesting and subtle and rich
topic of study.
But we have an opportunity
to multiplex workloads
across this global
infrastructure in a way that
lets us pass on cost
savings to our customers.
As an example, there are a few
of many potential computing
patterns, right?
There's the on-off sort
of batch every night.
Once a week, run this job.
You have the pattern
of growth, right?
Which is of course what we
all want in our businesses.
Up and to the right.
That means you
need more capacity.
And then there's a
third workload type--
this idea of burst.
And every workload, generally,
that's continuously on
is going to have
some pattern, right?
Absent any other capability, you
have to provision for the peak.
Or, if you're
optimistic, you provision
for some multiple
of the peak, right,
to avoid problems when you have
an unexpected spike in demand.
So all of these things, all
of these computing patterns,
if you have to manage
them yourselves,
you have to take on either
dramatic overprovisioning,
or provisioning for a
certain amount of growth,
or overprovisioning for these
batch periodic workloads.
With Google Cloud
Platform, you can
pass on all of that
complexity to Google.
You no longer need to plan
for every cycle of capacity
you need to run your business.
I'm not saying you don't
have to do some work,
but we are striving to take
away as much of that work
as possible.
Concretely, since 2006, we've
seen 6% to 8% price decreases
in public cloud
offerings annually.
But we don't think that's fair,
because the underlying costs
that actually drive the business
have been dropping at 20%
to 30% .
So that remaining red
area there is just
profit for the cloud provider.
Our intent is to actually
drive that red line
much closer to the blue line,
and pass on those savings
to our customers.
And you had seen that recently
as we announced new pricing.
And one concrete example
of that is our switch
in Compute Engine
pricing for On Demand.
Historically, you had to choose.
You had to choose between On
Demand and reserved compute
instances.
And generally, you
do that, if you're
running a complex enterprise,
you hire a capacity engineer.
You have to hire a person--
or more than one person--
to actually plan for that
capacity and optimize.
How much do I run on demand,
which is more expensive,
versus how much
do I run reserved,
which is less expensive,
but I'm committed
for some period of time.
So what we've done with
our new On Demand pricing
is as its usage increases
towards 100%, prices decrease.
So without you having to do
any specific engineering,
you just buy On Demand.
Right?
You buy On Demand instances,
and if you use them
like reserved
instances, they become
priced like reserve instances.
And that is just
sort of one data
point to hopefully give you
some feeling for how Google
is thinking about pricing
for the cloud platform.
But cloud is still too hard.
We want to price
it so you love it.
We want to make
it easy to get at.
But actually building
applications for the cloud
is still particularly
difficult in many ways.
Specifically developers need to
make trade-offs to get around
the way cloud
platforms in general--
not just ours-- are deficient
in a variety of ways.
And here are three kind
of classical trade-offs
that we see today.
A trade-off between time
to market or scalability.
Do I build my application, as
a startup, as a new project,
on day one to
scale, when I don't
know if it's going to scale?
Or do I build it so I get
to market most quickly?
And then deal with, ugh,
maybe it's not going to scale.
I'll do it later.
And often you have to step
in one of those two buckets--
either build it quick or build
it so it's going to scale.
Second example is flexibility
or automatic management.
So this, back to something
Tom said before, we believe
that the line between
infrastructure as a service
and platform as a service--
being maximum flexibility,
platform as a service
being minimal
management-- we believe
that that line is blurring.
And Julia is going to talk
about that in a little while.
And then, finally, we
also have to often choose
between big data--
store it efficiently,
make it cost-effective
to ingest and process--
or make it easy to access in
an ad hoc, real-time fashion.
Another trade-off
that's commonly made.
But we think in
most of these cases,
we can change that
"or" to an "and."
We can obviate the
trade-off in many cases.
So first one.
Time to market versus scale.
How do you smash those
two things together?
Well, we want to make
it possible to use
the tools that you as
developers know and love.
Make deployments fast, reliable.
And then make it easy to
fix problems in production.
And one big component of that
is Google Cloud Monitoring.
This is my team's
project, so I'm just
going to leave this slide
up here for a while.
Let you bask in its glow
of those nice graphs.
So the idea here is to
have a single pane of glass
for monitoring all
of your workload
on the Google Cloud Platform.
Give you rich
dashboards, alerting,
provide custom metrics, give you
an instant management facility,
make it possible to quickly
find and solve problems
in production systems.
Whether they're running on
App Engine or Compute Engine,
you have Cloud SQL databases.
You've got stuff deployed
globally across our network.
Stack Driver is the company
that we acquired back
in May that is the
foundation of this offering.
Another super-compelling
piece of this
is recognizing that if you're
making that trade-off, right?
Either I have super-flexible
or I have completely managed.
One of the common
complaints there
is that if I go to
the super-managed end
of the spectrum,
I lose visibility.
I lose the ability to debug
my application, right?
We've all typed gdb
binary core file.
Like, go in there, find
out, like, stack trace.
See which pointer id
reference is null.
You lose that, in most cases,
in a cloud environment.
You're running on App Engine.
You're running on
managed VMs, which
I'll talk about in a second.
You've got your processes
running wherever.
You don't have any
idea where it is.
You can't log into the box and
attach to the running process
and inspect the stack.
Cloud Debugger
offers the ability
to do exactly that in a
globally deployed application.
So you fire up the
Cloud Debugger.
If we have your source,
you set a breakpoint.
And we catch when
the breakpoint is
hit by the process
running, wherever
it happens to be
on our platform.
You see it.
You can inspect the stack.
Incredibly, incredibly
compelling capability.
And this was also
announced at I/O.
This is not generally
available yet.
And then another, final
example is Cloud Trace.
So we've all wanted
look at traces.
A hierarchical
decomposition of a request.
So we have an offering-- again,
not yet generally available,
but will be soon--
called Cloud Trace,
that lets you inspect for
a given App Engine request.
Inspect its complete trace
of calls into Datastore,
calls into memcache
to look for latency,
to look for deviant behavior
in your application.
And compare from
release to release.
Had release four, release five.
Release five seems to be
relatively less performant
than release four.
Where is the delta?
This tool will tell you.
OK.
The next trade-off that
we want to make go away--
that, again, Julia
will dig into--
is the trade-off between
flexibility and management.
Making it easy to manage
your application, right?
The App Engine kind of
platform as a service model.
Versus run whatever you
want, however you want,
but you lose the
management facility.
Again, we want to
make that go away
and blend together these two
models, the Turnkey App Engine
platform and the fully flexible
Compute Engine platform.
This is kind of
the conceptual view
of how this might
be accomplished.
At the bottom, you've
got Compute Engine.
We manage your infrastructure.
Then you get the idea
of replica pools, which
is a new facility in our Compute
Engine offering, where we take
care of multiple instances
sort of stamped out
of the same virtual
machine image.
And you can tell us to scale it.
We'll make sure that there
are n healthy at any given
point in time, by
doing health checks.
That's one additional
level of management.
Then up another
level is managed VMs,
where you give us
your App Engine app.
We run it in a virtual machine.
You don't have to log
into that virtual machine.
You don't have to
install software on it.
We take care of that for you.
But it's got your App
Engine app deployed in it.
And then at the
top of the stack,
we have so-called
managed runtimes.
This is the classic
App Engine model.
So in each of these
layers, you have
to have-- maybe not less code.
To me that's not quite
the right representation--
but you have to do less
management at each level.
One more plug for
my team's project.
We will provide logging and
monitoring across the spectrum.
So, regardless of whether
you're running a raw VM
or running on top of App
Engine, or anywhere in between,
we will give you visibility
into your complete application
portfolio.
So managed VMs, which
I mentioned before,
so this is the idea
that we can offer you
a virtual machine that is
managed like an App Engine app.
Containers.
This is one of the
newest things that we've
been doing in Google
Cloud Platform,
is offering
facilities to make it
easy to run containerized
applications on the Cloud
platform, by offering
special VM images that
are tuned for
running containers.
And, at the richest
end of the spectrum,
offering this new system
called Kubernetes,
which is a sort of miniaturized
cluster management system that
reflects on the lessons
that Google has learned
over many years of running
a large-scale cluster,
global managed cluster system.
So this lets us offer
better predictability.
Lets us do things with
resource allocation
that increase efficiency,
give you visibility
into how your resources
are being used.
So this I think is
extremely exciting,
an extremely exciting
offering from GCP.
And, perhaps more
importantly-- and you
might have seen this in
the press-- we're actually
working with a consortium of
tech companies-- including
Microsoft, somewhat
surprisingly--
to make this a
portable offering.
So that it operates
the same, regardless
of which cloud platform
you're running on.
So you can take your
containerized Kubernetes
application and run it in
any cloud with minimal pain.
Networking.
I think I went through
this a little bit already.
Our networks are great.
I won't dwell on it too much.
But I think this is generally
self-evident in the data.
Finally, big data.
So, again, trade-off between
big and fast, big and ad hoc
real time.
There's a variety of reasons
why big data is hard, right?
On one side of the coin, you
need specialized expertise.
You need complex
distributed infrastructure.
It takes a lot of energy to
build an efficient big data
system.
And then it's expensive.
The people that you have to hire
that have specialized expertise
are expensive.
Storage is expensive.
Compute is expensive.
So what we've decided to do
is, to the best of our ability,
make this easy and
affordable by bringing
to market a number of tools,
again based on the things
that we've done
internally at Google.
Based on our expertise
with MapReduce,
with large-scale SQL-like
systems like Spanner.
Data Flow, which is an evolution
of an internal system that
has largely supplanted
a raw MapReduce
for our internal
application workloads.
And, at the same time, make it
easy to run open-source systems
like Hadoop on Google
Cloud Platform.
So we're trying to put together
a portfolio of building blocks
to make big data accessible
to our customers.
Last point on this
is we're also working
on a fusion of
streaming computation--
that's the thing I mentioned
before Data Flow-- batch,
typical kind of
MapReduce-like applications,
and graph analysis,
graph databases.
Putting those together into a
portfolio that, again, gives
you the building
blocks that you need
to build the kinds
of applications
your business requires.
So, in summary, cloud's real.
I didn't have to sell that
one too hard, which is good.
The idea of the
Google Cloud Platform
is harnessing the
technology that we at Google
have used to build Google.
And, finally, all of these
software and infrastructure
innovations are
really coming of age.
And the Google
Cloud Platform has
as its mission to bring
those to our customers.
And to put our money
where our mouth is,
we have a so-called starter
pack credit available now
with this promotion code
applying at the URL there.
And get $500 to begin working
with the Cloud platform out
of the gate without
any upfront expense.
Thank you.